[Music]
a Michael Inman I'm curator of rare
books at the New York Public Library and
today we're looking at the hunt Linux
globe which is not only the second
oldest surviving terrestrial globe but
also the oldest known globe to depict
the Americas the origin the globe is
still somewhat shrouded in mystery
so far as we know it was created
probably in France or possibly Italy
roughly between the dates 1505 and 1510
there are a number of details on the
globe that I find interesting it's a
little bit hard to make out but here you
have a sea monster here at the end of my
finger
maybe that down slightly as well as a
ship these are just two examples of the
kinds of details that are hidden in the
globe in a sense and you know the more
you look at it the more these things do
pop out and it's here at the end of my
finger that we see just below the
equator the Latin phrase Hicks indirect
honies here be dragons are here live
dragons so today when you see a map
that's pretending to be yield map and a
ship sailing off the edge of the world
and it says here lies dragons that
phrase derived solely from the hunt
Linux globe then we have here South
America know North America however now
you see the landmass cuts off right
about where today's nation of Panama is
located so the Isthmus of Panama nothing
beyond that point is depicted well the
Newark Public Library has about 55
million items in its collection and
certainly this is one of the great
treasures has that treasure status and
because it is a completely unique object
and it speaks to Europeans knowledge of
the world just shortly after the time of
Columbus initial voyage when working
with something like this it really does
me anyway remind me of my tiny small
little individual place in history and
the fact that I'm just part of the long
continuum of people who have interacted
with this object and that it will be
around long after I and all of us are
gone
[Music]